[Música]
la pregunta la pregunta que me resuena y
que me choca es y ahora qué haces
exactamente y ahora dónde estás bueno
pues ahora estoy aquí en este espacio
estoy de ex universidad rey juan carlos
con todos vosotros y dispuesto a
compartir algunas reflexiones y algunas
y algunas experiencias
la verdad es que después de las
magníficas conferencias que hemos
escuchado lo último que me faltaba es
que el reloj me avisará que mis
pulsaciones se han acelerado
me vais a permitir qué
que hurguen en el árbol familiar y cómo
voy a hurgar en el álbum familiar voy a
tener que apoyarme en la caja digital
que tengo enfrente de mí y en este
dispositivo que es casi ya una prótesis
de uno mismo
soy explorador y desde pequeñito
un poco aventurero dentro de ese espacio
casi de seguridad que uno necesita
y por eso tengo que confesar que cuando
cuando víctor y fabio me propusieron
compartir este espacio
dudé muchísimo porque la verdad es que
aunque tengo ese espíritu aventurero y
ese espíritu de explorador limitado lo
que más me cuesta es como a tantos de
nosotros
es abrir la caja los cajones de la
intimidad esa caja de los recuerdos y de
las experiencias y de las reflexiones
que uno ha ido acumulando ya veis que
uno no es tan osado sino más bien un
poco tímido
pero entre fabio víctor y otro buen
amigo danny
me animaron a esto
con daniel comparto motor etc
que utilizan los componentes que creo
que necesita este nuevo mundo este el
mundo que llamamos futuro y que es
presente ya y que está en permanente
cambio
los componentes son generosidad
transparencia y compromiso
y descubrí compartiendo con ellos que
cuando uno abre esos cajones de la
intimidad recibe un chorro de energía un
chorro de energía para seguir adelante
que compartir experiencias y visiones
ayuda a meditar sobre lo que uno ha
hecho reflexionar sobre los errores
intentar no volver a cometerlos e
incluso a proponerse volver a meter la
pata otra vez y hacer de nuevo ese
ejercicio de reflexión sobre los errores
cometidos y las enseñanzas adquiridas
compartir con otros ayuda a plantearse
nuevas metas nuevas cimas nuevos
propósitos trazar nuevas rutas con los
mejores equipos con los mejores
compañeros
hace apenas un mes
murió mi padre
cuesta muchísimo decir que quienes han
aportado mucho a nuestras vidas quienes
han sido guías en nuestras vidas quienes
nos han enseñado mueren porque en
realidad estoy convencido de que nunca
mueren nunca desaparecen
los llevamos dentro sus enseñanzas son
la mochila de nuestras vidas incluso de
poquitos a poquitos de ese poquito que
nos aportan los amigos los familiares
los padres los equipos incluso los jefes
con los que trabajamos de esos poquitos
acabamos pareciéndonos un poco a ellos
con el tiempo
cuántas veces os habéis visto en
situaciones en eventos en cócteles en
reuniones de amigos os encontráis con
alguien a lo que no veis hace tiempo y
os preguntan y ahora que hace es
exactamente y ahora dónde estás pues
estoy aquí tomándome el vino la cerveza
el refresco contigo y estoy haciendo
esto contigo
a mí lo que me pide el cuerpo es
contestar lo que siento estoy en una
montaña rusa
a veces subo o trabajo a veces voy en
línea recta o tras giro y me adapto a la
situación casi siempre disfruto
a veces siento rabia
y permanentemente venzo al miedo
sobre todo
planteó nuevos propósitos me planteo
objetivos los comparto y busco a los
mejores aliados para llevarlos a cabo
no es la respuesta que todo el mundo
espera
la mayoría desgraciadamente una buena
mayoría todavía en estos tiempos de
cambio se siente más seguro si la
respuesta es imparto clases
así sobre empresas
incluso dirijo una revista
y todavía hay quien se sentiría mucho
más cómodo confortable si le respondiera
tengo un horario de 8 a 3 pronunciará
una marca de prestigio
y le tendría que pagar diciendo que esos
tiempos han pasado que esas rutinas de 8
horas se están acabando
que supongo que hay maestros mundiales
de los juegos del solitario estás
otras micras y estos otros juegos
fantásticos en el ordenador de la
oficina
y que lo que tenemos que romper son esas
rutinas exasperantes que estos tiempos
lo que necesitan son exploradores
aventureros
gente que se plantea nuevas metas para
un mundo que es absolutamente distinto
al que arrastramos desde la revolución
industrial
gente que pedalea dispuesta a cruzar
nuevos males
gente
y perdonar la alusión convencida como lo
estoy de que lo que no se sueña no se
construye y que para construir hay que
trabajar cada día con el horizonte
seguramente cambiante como las obras
empiezas un día
que fijan una fecha de terminación y
acaba terminando cuatro días más tarde y
con el baño colocado unos centímetros
más allá de donde lo habías planificado
lo que no se sueña no se construye suena
a una utopía suena utópico
pero y que si no a que si no nos
levantamos cada mañana si no es para
alcanzar la utopía que nos proponemos
lo vengo haciendo desde siempre como
muchos de vosotros de la universidad
desde esos tiempos
desde la universidad no me da la vida
pero como lo gozó la universidad por
cierto es un tiempo de experimentación
es un tiempo para abrir la mente y el
corazón para hacer amigos para leer
mucho para reflexionar sobre todo no es
una oficina de empleo y casi debilidad
que si es un gimnasio de la mente y del
corazón
a mí me permitirá dar el salto a aquello
que estudie si me permitió adentrarme en
el mundo del periodismo trabajando en
grandes cabeceras fueron pues quizás de
los mejores momentos de mi vida bueno
casi todos han sido buenos momentos en
mi vida
dejé el periodismo activo en aquella
época porque allí crecí y ahí me hice
mayor pero como esa propia industria
empecé a sentirme viejo
me surgió la oportunidad de dar el salto
y no solo de narrar lo que estaba
ocurriendo sino de participar en la
construcción una tarea titánica en plena
efervescencia del sector de las
telecomunicaciones en todo el mundo de
desaparición de los monopolios me dieron
la oportunidad de contribuir justamente
a la creación de una de las compañías
que iba a romper el monopolio de las
telecomunicaciones en españa fue un
auténtico placer trabajar en la
construcción de ese proyecto y aguantar
hasta la dya construcción y cuando
iniciamos la de construcción me surgió
la oportunidad de colaborar en una tarea
colectiva que era nada menos que
impulsar la sociedad de la información y
el uso de internet en españa integrando
a colectivos en riesgo de exclusión
llevando a internet a las escuelas
integrando en él lo que llamábamos era
la sociedad de la información fomentando
el uso de internet entre las personas
mayores o entre mujeres amas de casa
bueno cuando iniciamos aquella tarea
éramos 12 millones de internautas en
españa lo dejé con 20 millones
fue mi jefe el que me dijo misión
cumplida y yo como siempre he buscado me
despedí con la satisfacción del deber
cumplido
volvía
al ámbito privado
otra tarea enorme en el mundo
audiovisual en aquella época el mundo
audiovisual estaba cambiando
el objetivo que me marcaron era llevar
el mundo audiovisual tradicional de la
televisión y el cine básicamente al
mundo interactivo a internet eso que
ahora es lo transmedia
qué tanto nos resulta tan familiar nos
resulta bueno era una pequeña empresa
local que había que convertir en una
empresa interactiva de ámbito nacional y
buscar socios para seguir creciendo
se nos presentó una oportunidad enorme
acabaron comprando nos
y ganamos un pollo no es cierto
[Música]
de aquella fusión resulta una
conversación con el nuevo propietario de
la compañía
cuyo resultado fue esto que veis a igual
cual forrest gump me veis a mí al lado
de un presidente del gobierno fuera de
hago el despistado pero el presidente
del gobierno es el que está entrando y
yo a su lado aquella conversación nos
decía que me dio este salto fue contra
juan contamos mucho contigo en esta
fusión pero nosotros estamos radicados
aquí todo tu equipo y toda tu empresa
está radicada allí esto contamos contigo
pero yo dije no no no tranquilo ya está
tengo un nuevo propósito
y su pregunta fue esto lo buscaste o te
lo han propuesto y mi respuesta fue lo
que no se busca nunca se encuentra
llegué ahí al palacio de la moncloa en
uno de los momentos más difíciles de la
historia del capitalismo reciente año
[Risas]
sí sí me recibieron literalmente zafra
estás mucho más loco de lo que dicen de
ti
fue una época apasionante desde allá
arriba se ve todo uno intenta remar y
remar y remar y aportar su granito a una
situación
globalmente desastrosa
y se asomen es esa adversidad de la que
hemos oído hablar y cuesta muchísimo
asumir que no puedes torcer la realidad
de allí salí cesado los de 6 a 2 es muy
bonito en la jerga de ese ámbito en la
oficina del paro de diferente han echado
como a tantos millones de personas por
cierto en aquella época y tocaba
reinventarse otra vez y ahora qué haces
exactamente y ahora dónde estás
pues tenía que escribir en esa pizarra
en blanco lo que me proponía entonces y
lo que me propuse fue empezar de nuevo
había salido del mundo del periodismo y
dije ha pasado tanto tiempo ha cambiado
tanto el mundo que por qué no intentar
cambiar el propio mundo o bueno o por lo
menos hacer las cosas de otra manera a
cómo estaba yendo el mundo en aquel
momento en la industria periodística lo
intentamos
corta vida éxito aceptable la corta vida
fueron 18 18 meses del medio de
comunicación y el éxito bueno esa foto
que veis otra vez ahí está formada en al
lado de estos directores del periódico
recibiendo el premio
uno de los premios más importantes del
periodismo en españa- pero concede la
asociación de corresponsales de prensa
extranjera en españa nos dieron
sorprendentemente
un premio a la innovación lo
sorprendente es el título del premio
porque en el acta figura en la
innovación consistirá en la decidida
apuesta por la calidad frente a la
cantidad
era realmente nuestra apuesta
cerramos un mes después de esa foto que
habéis visto decir no
y ahora que hace es exactamente
pues exactamente no me canso nunca me
puse a estudiar me puse a estudiar dos
de las cosas que creo están cambiando el
mundo o dos de los ejes sobre los que
pivota el cambio en el mundo
inteligencia artificial y eso que
llamamos transformación digital por
cierto yo ya creo que somos más
digitales y analógicos y que esa
transformación va a consistir en
justamente asumir que ya somos más
digitales y que por tanto tenemos que
adaptar nuestra vida nuestra vida
analógica a la realidad digital en
digital somos mucho más colaborativos
mucho más abiertos mucho más
transparentes que lo que el miedo nos
impide serlo en el mundo analógico como
es el mundo de la oficina aburrida que
mostraba antes
dos ejes creo que están cambiando el
mundo aceleradamente la super
inteligencia que nos llevará y que nos
debe hacer reflexionar sobre el hecho de
que el empleo
es lo que deja de ser lo único que da
sentido a nuestras vidas y que por tanto
tenemos que empezar a pensar en qué
actividades vamos a desarrollar cuando
los automatismos los algoritmos los bots
nos liberen de muchas tareas
y la super longevidad el hecho de que
vayamos a vivir muchos años más
tenemos que dejar el asumir de que ese
periodo
de los jóvenes de la universidad de los
18 a los 21 años es el periodo de
formación porque vamos a vivir 100 años
más para hacerce los 20 y que por tanto
vamos a tener la oportunidad y la
necesidad de adaptarnos a muchas
realidades
hay ya muchos mundos en estas vidas en
esta en esta ruidosa pero también hay
muchas vidas en este mundo y vamos a
vivir muchas vidas en nuestra vida de
más de 100 años
leí este cartel hace unas semanas en
méxico que decía la vida es increíble me
he hecho porque no creo que la vida sea
increíble creo que lo que
lo que
las locas pero lo que ocurre es que
hacemos increíble nuestras vidas con
cada uno de los propósitos que nos
marcamos que la vida es un pasaje es un
viaje que vamos haciendo increíblemente
apasionante conforme vamos afrontando
una ruta u otra conforme nos vamos
marcando un destino u otro
lo que no se sueña no se construye lo
que no se busca no se encuentra
la felicidad le hará tener convicción
ser fiel a uno mismo
buscando aportar valor a nuestros seres
cercanos
teniendo en cuenta que cercano y ya es
cualquier ciudadano del mundo y no hay
nada que haga más feliz que ver felices
a quienes nos rodean
me preguntaron sobre mis primeros pasos
yo creo que mi primer paso como el de
todos ustedes está todavía por llegar
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]